hey everyone welcome back to dubai rapid
round eight this is a penultimate round
and coming into this round i was five
out of seven and if the title didn't
give it away we did go into a stafford
gambit but now the stafford gambit
accepted
my opponent uh thought for a little bit
after knight c6
and decided to turn down the gambit and
play knight f3
now i have received occasional comments
and requests of what to do when the
opponent climbs the stafford
and i know some people are maybe a bit
annoyed when the opponent doesn't take
on c6 which i will say right away if
you're a staffer gambit player as black
and your opponent plays knight f3 it's
already an opening success
black just regains the pawn and has a
slight lead in development
um now i actually covered this position
in a previous video
it was going over the game between hau
yifan and daniel dubov when duboff
played the staffer gamut
one of the first super gm's ever to do
so in a serious game
and he won the nice one after the move
d3 from hayfan
in this game my opponent played d4 which
is one of the most common moves
now another move which i'll quickly just
show because there's a cool line is if
white plays knight c3
black can play d5 and just reinforce the
knight
and create a situation where if takes
takes black is already doing quite well
initially against the knight and there's
not a great response for white either
knight g1
or queen e2 both moves have their their
drawbacks and there's actually another
video on youtube by the the youtube
channel the chess website
and they cover a line which goes queen
e2
and then black has a cool piece
sacrifice after bishop to b4
pawn d3
oh no my knight but then black just goes
ahead and castles
gives away the knight
and here you would maybe expect
something like d4 to try and regain the
piece but d4 there's a3
instead here black plays pawn takes e4
and if queen takes e4 we win the queen
uh
probably best move is knight d2 and then
there's knight d4
queen d1 bishop g4
objectively it's okay for white but uh
this is kind of the the style of the
staffer that we all know and love going
for super aggressive initiative white
would have to take and then takes here
king d1
engine will still give a small plus for
white but
again credit to the chess website
youtube channel who goes into this line
in a lot more depth
in this game we're going to see a
slightly quieter line with d4
and i play d5
and we reach a position where
the pawn structure is completely
symmetrical
but i'm basically up to tempe as black
because i already have a knight well
placed in the center on e4 and my
knights developed on c6
so going forward from here it's about
how i can try and maximize my slightly
development and get some early
initiative
so here my opponent plays bishop d3 i
play bishop g4
developing and pinning the knight having
some idea to take pawn on d4
my opponent plays c3 and i continue with
aggression queen to f6
not only pressuring the pinned knight on
f3 but getting ready to castle queenside
this is actually very typical in like
the stafford gambit decline positions
it's the castle queen side and then try
and access e-file as quickly as possible
especially when white hasn't castled yet
and here my opponent was probably a
little bit afraid of me taking and
giving double pawns
on the king side and went ahead and
played bishop to e2
the more natural move here is knight to
d2
which i was expecting
and this allows a few things i could
take and then take on f3 and force the
double pawns
but even stronger here is just a castle
and
essentially sacrifice upon an e4 now
it's not good for white to take it for
example if knight takes e4 pawn takes e4
bishop takes e4
black is already winning material by
force
after rook e8 pinning the bishop and
attacking the bishop
this would force queen e2
and then really nice move queen e7
creating the battery
preparing some f5 move
and if white plays bishop to d3 here
there's a really really nice tactic that
i found earlier with the help of
stockfish but
i'll give it to the viewers this is
black to move and find the beautiful way
to win material feel free to pause the
video if you need more time to find the
move but the move is knight takes d4
just a beautiful resource
um hitting the queen hitting the knight
and all the tactics work out for black
if pawn digs d4 there is a nice shot
queen b4
discovered attack on the queen
and this is pinning the queen so there's
no queen d2 if bishop d2 we take the
queen with check
and black would go up a queen
and uh what else can i do here queen
takes e7 we just take back with check
and we're winning some more material on
f3 with a really nice position
so um
that would have been a nice line if my
opponent played the most natural move
but after bishop e2 i just continue to
develop and improve with bishop d6 and
here my opponent plays a double attack
queen to b3
hitting two undefended pawns
but i'm not really afraid in this
position because i have such a big lead
in development even if white wins a pawn
it's gonna take more time and the more
time light wastes without developing
pieces and getting the king safe more
chances i'll have to attack
and i very simply castle queen side in
this position hovering d7 getting the
rook to the d-file
and uh yeah i can say that this move
probably just runs into so much trouble
uh here the engine oh engine recommends
a really nice shot knight takes f2 idea
king takes f2 bishop g3
winning the queen in style so when that
queen's like castle i knew that there
were going to be some tactics in the air
and uh already on move nine
white is uh severely behind development
i have all my minor pieces developed my
king castle my queen developed
and uh things are looking really good
right from the gecko um but it's not
over as we're gonna see opponent plays
bishop to e3
i play rook e8
knight bd2
and here i play bishop to f4 i'm again
trying to be as aggressive as possible
trying to create a situation where it
will be very easy for white to go wrong
and there are a lot of ways for white to
just lose material in this position for
example if castling
this just walks into knight takes d2
and something is going to hang in the
end given that this bishop is pinned to
e2
along with the knight actually both
minor pieces are are pinned to the e2
bishop and black is just winning a lot
of material here
so after bishop f4 my opponent played
knight takes e4 which is the best move
we trail on e4
and now knight to g1
and even though it looks like really
really ugly for black white is trying to
create some sort of fortress and
make it difficult for me to break
through and i realized here that if i
just trade on e2 or e3
it really just helps white uh solidify
the position
and i figured it would be best to
retreat my like squared bishop to e6
hit the queen deep initiative
i forced the queen back to c2
and here i play the move which i thought
was really nice in the moment queen to
h6
creating pressure against the bishop on
e3
trying to provoke the exchange where
then maybe later i could play pawn e3
it turns out i missed an even stronger
idea
to take on e3 right away
and after f takes e3 play the move queen
to h6
which very simply targets e pawn
and uh it's a clear weakness in white's
position which perhaps looks easy to
defend with a move like queen d2
but after a really nice move 97
i'm coming with knight d5 or knight f5
and if white loses e3 then the whole
position will very likely collapse
if white wants to defend e3 then king f2
will probably need to be played but that
just looks terrible
so i missed the opportunity to take on
e3 and after queen h6
my opponent showed that he still has
some life left i had to move queen d2
and here the difference is that when i
take on e3
white doesn't have to take back with the
pawn but rather can take back with the
queen
and this is a position where i don't
want to trade queens because that would
just kill my chances to attack in the
middle game
and
i played the move queen g6 and i was
still feeling really comfortable here
because the queen on e3 is a black hater
and uh
as we know in chess queens do not like
to be the one black hating pawns um just
because if they're attacked they
basically have to move and i still have
the idea of playing f5 maneuvering that
knight to d5 was very optimistic but uh
opponent found some some nice moves like
queen to g3 offering a queen trade i
said no thanks
and now queen e3 again offering a queen
trade
again i said no thank you
and now pawn g3 so we did a little a
little bit of a dance here
i moved back to f6
and here pawn h4 was played which is
again a slightly annoying move because
white is preparing to play queen g5
which would force a queen trade
so again i
i politely
said no thank you played pawn h6
and sometimes in these positions it
requires a preventive play to
secure the the longer term advantage so
h6 even though it's a slow move um it is
preventing white's main idea and i'm
still questioning how white will
complete development
93 was played the only developing move
for the knight
and this actually gave me an interesting
decision because
looks like the knight is not so happy
but it's about to come to life
with knight f4
and i thought for a little bit here and
decided to take on h3
and even though this gives away a nice
central bishop
it does misplace white's rook i thought
i would get a situation where eventually
i'll play queen e6
f5 and just have a really nice structure
against white's bishop and
just better pieces in white overall so
here i did play queen e6
opponent played queen f4 which is a
tricky move
i was imagining my opponent playing this
move and and saying oh no my rook of
course i can't take the rook because
bishop g4 so
we can say the rook is defended by
tactics and bishop g4 is a major major
threat here so played the very simple
move king db8
and bishop g4 was still played i moved
my queen away
and now queen to f5 so again this pesky
queen
trying to trade of course from white's
perspective it makes sense to go into an
end game where longer term maybe the
bishop could potentially be better than
the knights
so i i slide back
and
here i am offering a pawn on f7
however if white takes the pawn there
are a few different ways to continue
there's actually a really nice move here
95
which i don't know if i saw in the game
of course stockfish is pointing at out
here
which is essentially a major fork not
only against the queen and bishop also
threatening knight d3
and white can't really get away with
taking it because after queen d2 king f1
rook f8 is lights out for white
skewering the queen and the eventual
mating square on f2
white would have to just lose the queen
here or play a move like rook d1 and
then i'll be up uh exchange there's
still a lot of pressure on f2 e3 coming
so long story short
f7 is a poison pawn
my opponent made a good decision didn't
take it but rather castle queenside
and here comes kind of a more strategic
battle where
we were both getting pretty low on time
we can see already my opponent
has just over a minute left i was below
four minutes
and the next many moves came pretty
quickly a lot of the moves are
like solidifying and improving moves
from both sides
i played queen e7 uh now defending the
pawn
i had the idea of eventually playing g6
and f5
which did happen after rook h1 g6 queen
b5 f5 i will say this is a common type
of principle in chess
when you have a knight versus a bishop
and these are the only minor pieces on
the board
usually it makes sense to put your pawns
on the same color
as opponent's bishop
just to restrict the bishop now this
would be different if i had a light
square bishop i would want my pawns on
dark squares but in this situation i'm
very happy that my pawns can essentially
dominate the lights for a bishop and
white had to sadly retreat back to e2
i play queen d6 here uh just improving
the queen
trying to have some scope of either
playing e3 or f4
which i thought will ultimately be the
way i make progress here
opponent played came to b1
i played queen f6
rookie 1 was played rookie 7.
so in a rapid game especially
moves like queen f6 and rookie 7 they're
not the most
forcing or
aggressive moves but they're they're
very easy moves to play which don't
really change the overall structure or
dynamic of the position in any way and i
was really just trying to maximize the
pressure against my opponent and wait
for the right opportunity to strike
my opponent here plays f4 which
could be considered a slight positional
mistake because it essentially gives me
a really strong and defended pass pawn
probably would have been better to leave
the pawn back on f2
but f4 was played
i play rook ed7
queen a4
and now knight to e7
so again i'm just trying to make gradual
improvements i had some idea of
maneuvering the knight either to d5 or
to c8 and then eventually to b6 to keep
my my king safe and also to target the
queen
opponent plays queen to b3
i play knight c8 i was half hoping for
bishop a6 here which looks to be really
aggressive but just walks into
queenjig's a6
of course my opponent did not blunder a
bishop played pawn a4 and here i finally
go ahead with the kingside pawn break on
g5
and given that my opponent is below a
minute i thought now is the time to try
and complicate things a little bit on
the king side
uh white took
i took
and rook to f1 nice move very solid uh
creating a scenario where i don't want
to take because then after rook takes
off f4 my f pawn is a backwards pawn and
rook tf1 could come
and i could possibly lose a pawn here
so instead i left the tension played
rook to g7
and the point of this move is i'm
waiting for white to take because if
light goes ahead and takes on g5
i take back with rook
and i can make the argument that g3 is a
bigger weakness than f5 f5 is already
well defended g3 is undefended and very
easy to put more pressure on
so
yeah we left the tension
opponent played queen to b5
a nifty move attacking laterally against
f5
i played knight t6 hitting the queen
defending f5
and now queen's e5
again going for the queen trade and uh
yet again i don't want to trade queens
because if i take it uh can really help
improve white structure
so i just slide over to g6 and here my
opponent played g4
and this is where things start getting
really spicy just given all the pawn
tension
and i didn't really have much time to
calculate all the nuanced variations
here
so i played what looks to be a very
intuitive move
rook e8
counter attacking white's queen on e5
and my opponent surprised me here a
little bit and
instead of moving the queen
silicon f5
counter attacking my queen and when this
move was played i
i thought it was just a massive mistake
i very quickly take back with my knight
and now if we see the queen is attacked
and i'm threatening knight e3 with a
fork of the rooks
so here i just assumed i'm winning
and my point uh clearly wasn't happy
and
after a little bit of thought move back
to b5 and i happily played 93 and won
the exchange
it turns out in this position
after knight takes f5
white has a miracle move
which i only just discovered
from from stockfish it's amazing the
resources stockfish can point out
after a game like this but this is white
to move and equalize
there's only one move which just doesn't
lose on the spot
and it's a pretty incredible move
if you don't see it already feel free to
pause the video and think
but it turns out that white does not
have to move the queen but rather can
unleash yet another counter attack
bishop to h5
and i'm very happy my opponent didn't
play this move because it would have
flustered me
a good deal
um given that now both queens are
hanging
if i take the bishop
white can happily take on f5
and it looks like the
the pawn tension on the king's side if
anything is going in white's favor
because my g pawn is pinned my e4 pawn's
potentially weak
black's just not better here
another cool line is
if i take the queen on e5
yeah white could take back on g6 and it
would be a trade
but
even better for white
is pawn takes e5
not recapturing the queen
but threatening maiden one and it turns
out white's just completely winning here
there's no good way to defend against
the double threat from light
now i do have the move queen e6 but this
would walk into rook d8
queen c8
x takes and bishop g4 in the end
and white's winning the piece on f5 if i
defend
fg5 and there's no saving the knight
which is pin to my king and pin to my
rook so this could have
easily happened if my opponent found
bishop h5
but i'm very thankful the uh the tactics
gods were on my side so after i took on
f5 my opponent missed opportunity played
queens of b5 which looks like it hits a
rook but the rook's defended and i
happily go into e3
working the rooks on the first rank
opponent takes
i take a rook
takes
and from this point forward it was just
a matter of cleanup
and not blundering anything
i do have an extra rook for a bishop
this pawn is weak
and we'll see the technique here
first i make luft hit the queen
force the queen away
played king a7 i could have taken on g5
but this would allow bishop a6
so i didn't want to be in any rush just
giving like no chances of counter play
opponent plays king to a1
take
queen c4
rook d7
a lot of these moves were just a matter
of conserving time and not getting too
low
now here's a moment where i want to
trade queens because i'm up material
opponents said no thank you so there
were a lot of uh
polite
declining of queen trades this game from
both sides
uh here i go ahead play e3
on a5 and queen g2 and i figured that if
white won't trade queens with me i might
as well use my queen as a weapon i hit
the bishop trying to make progress with
my deadly past epon
opponent throws in a check
king b1 and now queen c4 defending the
bishop
and here it's a matter of just trying to
remove the blackhead on e2
and to do that i slide over to that file
going for rook to f2
opponent plays bishop to d3
and i play rook to e7 just fully
optimizing both rooks upon d5 and now i
play pawn e2
it felt like my e pawn was moses
crossing the red sea
opponent now tries to blockade on e1
i have the nice move rook to f1
and even though white is technically
controlling f1
three times
once with the rook but then also twice
with x-ray vision
um i can afford to play rook f1 because
if white takes
takes takes i have rookie one to win the
bishop in the end
so uh yeah tactics were on my side here
so after rook f1 my opponent played pawn
d6 kind of a desperation move
i took on e1 king a2
click on d6 bishop f5 rook c7
and i do have to give credit to my
opponent for finding the one last trick
in the position
uh played the move queen to g8
and i will say if i was in white's shoes
i would have done the same
and
for anyone thinking that black should
just play king a7 and
and be happy
you would then blunder your queen on g2
so thankfully i saw i could just hate
the queen and my opponent proudly
resigned
now i will say this was a bit
reminiscent of what carlson tried to do
against me the one time i beat him in
chess 960.
enough when i take it
good try
good try
queen f1 very sneaky
he played a very similar move hitting my
king hitting my queen from afar
and thankfully in this game and in that
game i spotted
the right move take the free queen and
force my opponent to resign
so uh that was round eight
my opponent got into trouble in the
opening
from a staffer gambit declined
probably the takeaway for my opponent is
to learn to accept the stafford and try
and punish the opening for next time but
even though i got a good position it
took a lot of work to convert and my
opponent did defend well and almost
fully recovered from really really bad
opening
so this game put me at six out of eight
points in the tournament
going into the ninth and final round
and uh stay tuned for
the recap of round nine if i win round
nine uh there were some cash prizes on
the line
and i did have a really fun game to
finish off the tournament as always if
you have questions comments feedback
leave them in the comments below
i do look forward to seeing your
comments and i'll see you in the next
video